so i originally wanted to do an episode
going through stranger things and
calculating what level all the
characters would be if they were a party
in dungeons and dragons considering all
the monsters they've beaten all the
adventures they've gone on all the
soviets they've outsmarted they've got
to be getting up there in the levels
right like level 15 at least so i busted
out some old rule books for the ancient
first edition advanced dnd that was
around back when the show takes place
and did some calculations and then i
learned that basically no one has gotten
anywhere apparently leveling up in
classic dnd was just really hecking hard
the only character that's done enough to
level up throughout the entire show is
hopper it turns out that beating up all
those guards and soviets killing a horde
of demogorgons and looting a whole
freaking snowmobile added up just over
one level's worth of xp just one level
don't worry hop vector's only considered
to be a demigod of greater power i have
no doubt that a level 2 fighter can beat
him
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that's always running up that
hill called the youtube algorithm today
we're journeying into the upside down
with all our favorite kids from hawkins
indiana though can we even call them
kids at this point how much time there
is between seasons of this thing dustin
over here is looking like he's ready to
put a down payment on his first mortgage
honestly though it's not just the kids
who've grown up either it's wild to
think just how much the stranger things
franchise has grown since it first
premiered i mean this thing started as a
mid-budget homage to classic 80s movies
and now it's got a budget that's larger
than not only those cinematic classics
but also modern day blockbusters
seriously netflix spent
270 million dollars on stranger things
season four compare that to the biggest
movie of 2022 so far top gun maverick
that thing had a budget of only 170
million how do you even afford that
don't worry netflix has got themselves a
plan you know they could have taken my
advice from a previous episode but nah
they've got a better idea they're
betting the farm on a stranger things
pop-up shop in paris so what sort of
things do you think you can buy
from stranger things the store
wow
look at all that specialty merch like
trucker hats gotta be honest with you
netflix something tells me that you
might need to do a bit more than sell a
few t-shirts to break even on this one
now in case you've somehow missed one of
the biggest streaming shows ever
stranger things is the story of four
nerdy friends five nerdy friends six
seven eight netflix slow down it's no
wonder the budget for this thing is so
huge you're adding like three new
ongoing main characters every season
anyway every season the small football
teams worth the nerds are tasked with
trying to save themselves their hometown
and the world from the upside down a
dark mirror dimension full of spooky
scary monsters but despite having more
than enough warm bodies to throw at the
nearest threat every season ultimately
boils down to one character eleven a
young girl with incredible psychic
powers and terrible arts and crafts
powers and for my visual aid i made
a dirayama
of our cabin oh yeah and sometimes some
of them go to russia and stay there for
way too long seriously you hadn't out
written into the story why did you
double down guys sorry just had to get
that off my chest if you know you know
anyway the newest season introduced us
to basically the final boss of the whole
show the bone-breakingly powerful vecna
another powerful psychic coming from the
same training program as 11. this guy is
scary and he immediately makes a huge
first impression but even more
incredible is the fact that he's been
teased in the series since episode one
of season one notice the key turning
right here yeah the big bad of season
one is the demogorgon and that's not a
psychic monster that right there has to
be vectors doing also you got this clock
noise that's heard before will enters
the upside down
how cool is that in the opening minutes
we're teased about this guy who only
appears a couple seasons later tldr here
the show's been building to his reveal
for a long time they even show that
vecton has been the one actively
controlling all the other monsters from
the previous seasons in short this dude
is a big deal which means that no matter
how long you stand there with your arm
outstretched 11 it ain't gonna work and
we see this in the season's final
episode despite being lit on fire shot
point blank with a shotgun having parts
of his hive mind severed and falling
several stories out a window vecna
escapes and he'll be back for the final
season will makes that abundantly clear
i can feel him and he's hurt
he's hurting
but he's still alive so what else can
our lovable team of geeks do how do you
kill this seemingly unkillable foe well
i think that we actually have a
blueprint for exactly how to beat this
guy thanks to a little game called
dungeons and dragons this tabletop rpg
is obviously core to the lore of
stranger things oh jesus we're so
screwed if it's the demogorgon it's not
the demogorgon an army of tropical
that's charged into the chamber
chocolates told you
but i'm not sure many people realize
just how influential it's been so today
we're gonna look at the pieces stranger
things is set up throughout the series
and examine the lore of the franchise
through the lens of d to tell you
exactly what vecna's plan is and how
they're ultimately gonna stop him
spoiler alert our lovable gang from
hawkins indiana are gonna have to make a
couple horrible sacrifices to do it
millie bobby brown the actress playing
eleven she recently said in an interview
that she wished that the show had more
deaths well let me be the first to tell
her she's gonna get them this next
season in fact i have a strong suspicion
as to who's gonna die next season and
their deaths won't be completely
pointless like eddie's sidenote loved
eddie as a character it's cool and all
that you got to do that epic guitar solo
but seriously these guys are smarter
than that they thought through their
plan they could have just set up a tape
to play on top of a speaker system and
don't even get me started on the whole i
need to buy them time thing no just no
hashtag justice freddy he was too cool
and too smart he deserved a better death
okay rant over so can i predict the
ending of a show whose ending hasn't
even been written yet and likely won't
air for at least another year and a half
when mike is old enough to join aarp hop
on your trailers friends today we're
shredding some lore so first off just to
be clear stranger things has made no
effort to hide how much of its mythology
is inspired by dungeons and dragons i
mean all of its main monsters are
straight up named after famous dnd
enemies but names aren't the only thing
that they borrow the basic concepts
behind the d d monsters are also
incorporated into the stranger things
iterations think about it like that meme
where you copy your friend's homework
but you change it just enough so you
won't get into trouble if you want an
example just take a look at season
three's mind flayer in the game mind
flares are illiterate technical faced
creatures from a different plane of
existence that operate a hive mind
telepathically controlling intelligent
creatures as minions and reproducing via
creepy slugs that infect the brains of
host bodies now take a look at stranger
things their mind flare is a hive mind
check from a different plane of
existence check that often takes the
form of creatures with tentacles check
it has the ability to control the minds
of people like we see with billy check
and the demogorgons controlled by the
mind flare will reproduce with gross
slugs that live in hosts like will
check again and this pattern holds true
for vechna too if you play dnd you knew
that things were about to get serious
the second they revealed the dude's name
in the game vecna is a lich basically an
absurdly powerful undead wizard he also
holds the title master of the spider
throne cool name terrible building
material for a throne he's also the
closest thing to a thanos that you're
going to get in d d in one of the most
famous vechna stories the adventure
starts with him killing the council of
eight collection of the strongest
sorcerers in the entire world talk about
making your presence known for a while
the only parts of vekna that remained in
the world of dnd were his eye and his
hand and those alone were considered
legendary artifacts with the ability to
grant incredibly evil powers the long
and short of all of this is while we
can't look at d and d lore as a hard
blueprint for exactly what's gonna
happen we can use it as a sort of cheat
sheet to get an idea of where the show
might be headed to next so how does all
of that map onto stranger things well as
i just mentioned vecna is the true ruler
of the upside down but he's not native
to it he's actually a human boy named
henry creel the very first child become
part of the experiments where eleven
honed her powers this in turn gave him
the moniker one to kill him back now
slash henry
he might not be a powerful wizard but he
is a powerful psychic he may not sit
atop a spider throne but he does like
spiders and just like dnd's vekna killed
the other mages in the council of eight
one in stranger things killed all the
other powerful kids in the psychic
experiments to start his story in fact
eleven gets so angry in this moment that
she basically tears him apart it's only
once he's in the upside down that he's
able to regain his strength in short
henry is quite literally killed and then
reborn in a lot of ways you could say
that he's undead just like vecna the
lich and remember the whole eye and hand
being powerful artifact thing from d d
while vector in the show is shown with
one enlarged hand and is just oozing
with eye imagery the parallels here are
very clear and this is even looking past
how stranger things as vector looks an
awful lot like some incarnations of the
d d character so a lot of that lines up
really well and that naturally got me
asking what else in vecna's dnd lore can
we look at to figure out what the next
season is going to do well most
iterations of the character have one
major goal to become a god vechna's been
trying to do it for basically as long as
he's been around and he's even succeeded
in some dnd storylines that's also going
to be vecna's goal in stranger things as
one explains in season four imagine what
we could do together we could re-shape
the world we make it however we see fed
he's likely going to do this by
transporting a great deal of the upside
down out into the real world if what
nancy sees in her vague vision of the
future is to be believed he showed me
things that haven't happened yet there
were so many monsters an army and they
were coming into hawkins and this
actually lines up with perhaps the most
popular iteration of the character one
that predates stranger things i'm
talking about vecna's appearance as the
villain from the massively popular dnd
livestream critical role he wasn't
really going to offer information anyway
who are you standing by the doorway you
see their arms crossed
casually standing before you
now before you bring it up yes critical
role is independent from d d's publisher
wizards of the coast but because of its
popularity wizards frequently references
the events of critical role as part of
dnd canon in short the stories of
critical role in their version of vechna
are absolutely parts of the dnd canon
that we can look at to chart the future
of stranger things and in that story
vecna bides his time building his power
in a realm called the shadowfell a dark
reflection of the real world often
associated with spider gods dark
reflections of the real world filled
with spider-like things you say hmm
in the end vecna teleports his entire
army from the shadowfell out to the real
world attacking a major city before the
heroes stop him so i expect that
stranger things is going to follow that
basic outline as well but the bigger
question is obviously not what he's
gonna do but rather what do you do to
stop him is there anything in the dnd
lore that can tell us what our main
characters need to do thankfully yes in
fact the way to stop vecna is
foundational to his lore you see one
constant across every incarnation of the
character is that he's betrayed by his
right hand man the vampire lord cast the
bloody hand in that is dead killed by
cats so it was thought my friend so it
was thought see vekna made the classic
bad guy mistake of trusting another bad
guy elevating coss and granting him a
powerful magic weapon that would
eventually come to be known as the sword
of coss of course koss eventually uses
this sword to cut off vecna's hand and
rip out his eye before banishing him to
another realm in the present day the
sword of koss remains one of the only
ways to destroy the remaining artifacts
of ekna so clearly stranger things is
gonna have their own iteration of costs
in fact many online theorists think that
they've already got a handle on who
exactly the betrayer is gonna be so
let's quickly talk about that in a mini
morty we're gonna talk about a popular
theory for just a minute that's why we
call it a mini morty
a popular theory that's been floating
around the old reddits is that the late
great eddie munson is gonna return as
the show's iteration of koss according
to them koss was most well known for
using a sword just like eddie uses
against the demobats during the final
battle koss was a vampire lord creatures
often associated with bats and eddie was
killed by a swarm of demobats plus the
choice of metallica's master of puppets
as the song that eddie rocks out to
could be foreshadowing that he'll be
risen as coss under vecna's control they
specifically point to lyrics like master
of puppets i'm pulling your strings
twisting your mind and smashing your
dreams and while i think i made it clear
earlier just how much i'd love to see
eddie get some well-deserved justice i
just don't think the parallels here make
a lot of sense first off yeah eddie uses
a sword i guess but there's nothing
special about that particular sword if
anything eddie's guitar was his much
more iconic weapon you could say that
he's much more of a bard character who
uses an axe secondly well yeah he did
die to demo bats steve also got bit real
bad by the bats so the connection isn't
just with eddie finally the lyrical
connection between master of puppets and
vekna is really cool but the show
runners made it clear that eddie's
guitar solo wasn't originally planned
all they knew was that eddie was just
gonna distract the demobats in some way
they didn't know how the concert angle
wasn't pitched until very late in the
writing process after the main beats of
the story including eddie's death had
already been set in stone master of
puppets was also chosen after the scene
was conceived partially because the
lyrics which described drug addiction
not only matched up so well with vechna
but also eddie's past as a drug dealer
do i think that eddie might come back
reincarnated or as a vision in some way
sure especially considering how popular
he was this season but do i think that
he's costs and will bring down vecna no
the biggest reason for that actually has
nothing to do with bats or swords i
think that there's already a far better
candidate for koss one that's already
completed part of the thematic arc for
the character within d and d lore 11.
yeah i know shocking revelation that the
main character might have the best shot
at beating the main villain but who else
did you expect see one was the person
that encouraged eleven to embrace her
powers taking her on as his right-hand
man in that way it's his encouragement
that ultimately helps her find herself
in our dnd comparison that parallels the
way vecna uplifted koss and gave him his
sword one even offers l a place at his
side when he reveals his plan to take
over the world again like their d d
counterparts however just like vecna was
betrayed by kos 11 betrays one by using
her powers her sword to rip open the
very first portal into the upside down
throwing one inside just like coss
banished vecna so true to form it's
clear that this is the direction that
they're taking with eleven and even if
taking down vecna is gonna be a team
effort from the full cast l and her
powers are absolutely the sort of cost
that's going to be needed to deliver the
final blow but there's one final piece
to our puzzle here like i said when we
first introduced the d d bad guy vekna's
a lich and the thing about liches is
that they're undead they sacrifice their
humanity for immortality ripping their
souls out of their bodies and putting
them into magical objects called
phylacteries as long as the lich's
phylactery remains intact they literally
cannot die think of a phylactery like a
horcrux from harry potter now just like
other dnd concepts borrowed by stranger
things i don't think the show's vecna
literally ripped his soul out of his
body and put it into a baseball or
whatever but with vecna coming back next
season despite being lit on fire shot
point-blank with a shotgun and falling
several stories out of a window think
it's safe to say that he may have
himself some phylacteries lying around
so if the hawkins gang want to put an
end to vecna once and for all they're
gonna have to find that phylactery and
destroy it sadly d d lore is very
secretive about what exactly their
vechna uses as his phylactery so we're
not going to be able to find a clean
equivalent within stranger things but
that doesn't mean that we can't figure
it out in fact i think what vecna's
phylactery is on the show is kinda
obvious we already know that vecna's
connected to the mind flare's hive mind
and that when he kills people with his
powers they join that hive mind and
increases strength they're not gone
eleven
they're still with me
likewise when something like a
demogorgon dies vecna is weakened so it
would make sense that 11 and the others
would need to destroy that hive mind to
weaken vecna so he can be defeated
there's just one problem with that
there's someone else that's tapped into
the hive mind will byers ever since he
was trapped in the upside down in season
one will has had some sort of a
connection to the realm to the mind
flair and now to vechna he begins seeing
glimpses of it in the real world he
begins to draw the same spidery shape
that vecna was obsessed with when he was
a child more explicitly in season two
vekna and the mind flare use will as a
vessel possessing his body and
puppeteering him like a marionette and
since then will can feel vecna he senses
when he's in pain or when he's nearby in
the upside down and that means that will
is likely a major part of that
phylactery that'll need to be destroyed
in order to kill vecna it also provides
an added layer of bookending to know
that the series started with a
season-long mission to keep will alive
but will end with a season-long mission
that requires the team to kill him and
honestly this is just a brilliant setup
for a beautifully tragic storyline
eleven has been welcomed into the
buyer's family as one of their own an
adopted daughter they love eleven and
eleven loves them and now she has to go
and kill her own adopted brother but of
course will's not gonna be alone in this
there's a very real possibility that
we're gonna lose a lot of our beloved
idiots remember that vision of the
future that vekna showed mike's sister
nancy while parts of it have already
explicitly come true he
showed me
a dark cloud
spreading over hawkins
downtown on fire but the vision didn't
stop there for nancy he showed me my mom
holly
mike
that's right if other parts of that
foretelling come true mike is likely
going to eat it next season as well
which will destroy everyone who loves
him as they made explicitly clear this
season mike is the leader he's the heart
of the team see how you're leading us
here you're guiding the whole party and
inspiring us and see your coat of arms
here it's it's hard that's what holds
this whole party together heart so what
better way for vecna to strike than by
ripping out the heart by killing off the
one character that gave 11 the boost
that she needed to overcome him here's
the way that i see it all going down the
team realizes that will is the final
phylactery the thing that's keeping
vecna alive and that he has to die by
eleven's hand her power her sword of
course except there's one problem she
can't do it will and her are like
brother and sister he's the one person
who understands her
it's gonna be okay
it's not that bad
we'll fix it together okay however mike
and the rest of the family are killed
during the final battle dealing critical
emotional damage to both will and eleven
enraged and devastated eleven does what
she has to do she turns and kills will
the boy that everyone on the show has
been trying to keep alive since the very
first episode and this is the final act
that allows vecna to finally die from
there you have to deal with the
bittersweet aftermath on one hand the
buyers are grateful that the world is
saved but at the same time they can't be
around 11 one who took will away from
them this then puts a strain on the
relationship between joyce and hopper
and the rest of the crew suddenly has to
find their new roles without mike their
heart their team leader to guide them
and hey this sets up some awesome sequel
potential i mean netflix has already
announced that they are milking this
cash cow as far as it'll go with a whole
stinking production company called
upside down pictures and a spin-off
where an emotionally scarred adult 11
travels the world getting up to psychic
shenanigans in the waning years of the
cold war yep seems like a pretty safe
bet to me or you know i could be
completely wrong and they just decide
that they're gonna bring back that
long-lost sister of hers from that one
random episode in season two nah i don't
think anyone even netflix is that
desperate but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and cut
[Music]
you